the species comparison tool allows you
to compare human pathways with other
species to see what is common to both or
perhaps missing in humans or in the
model organism
species comparison is launched using the
analyze data button in the pathway
browser header bar
or the analyze button at the top of the
pathway browser
in the species comparison section select
one of the species in the drop down list
click the go button reactome uses the
manually curated human pathways to
computationally infer their equivalence
in other species
this inference process is based on gene
orthology
using the ensemble kompara database
biological processes are remarkably well
conserved over large evolutionary
distances
even though our focus is to annotate the
molecular details of human biological
events
we can use protein sequence orthology
relationships to ask whether the human
proteins involved in the reaction have
orthologs in the model organism
if the orthologs exist in the ensemble
compara resource
we computationally infer the
corresponding reaction for the model
organism
and in this way build up a predicted
pathway knowledge base for the organism
clicking on pathway nodes displays the
relevant pathway diagram
the color of reaction objects indicates
the result of the comparison
yellow indicates that the protein has an
inferred equivalent in the comparison
species
blue indicates that no equivalent was
identified
this protein may not exist in the
comparison species
no color indicates that inference was
not possible
this is always the case for small
molecules dna and other objects that
have no uniprot entry
objects with bands of color represent
complexes or sets containing more than
one molecule
the bands of color reflect the inference
success for the molecules within the
complex or set
the species comparison bar at the bottom
of the pathway diagram can be used to
turn
off species comparison coloring
to see the species comparison results
for the components of a complex
hover your mouse over the object and
open the information panel
traditionally reactions in reactome
represent events that occur within
a single generic human cell it would
however
be useful to classify reactions into
different human tissue types
as to provide an evolving picture of the
reactions and pathways in different cell
and tissue-specific environments
this tool allows users to understand the
pathways that are enriched in different
human tissue types
based on protein expression data tissue
distribution is launched using the
analysis button in the pathway browser
header bar in the tissue distribution
section
select the one experimental tissue data
set hpa
eprot3 expression atlas in the drop-down
list
we have imported protein expression in
different cell or tissue types from the
human protein
atlas or hpa overlaid these proteins on
reactant data
and extracted the subset of reactions
for that particular cell type
the hpa data reflecting the expression
of the protein coding genes in 44
different human tissues can be
visualized through the analysis tools
once the window refreshes select the
available tissues in the left panel
and hit the add button to add tissue
expression data to the analysis tool
press the at all button if you would
like to adjoin all the tissue expression
data
use the remove all and remove buttons to
delete tissue expression data from the
filter list
once you have selected all the
appropriate tissues click the go button
to start the analysis
an over-representation analysis is
performed on the protein expression data
of each tissue type
the results of the tissue distribution
analysis are presented similar to that
of over-representation users can use the
slider at the bottom of the diagram
panel to toggle between the selected
tissue types
the analysis tab in the details panel
contains the enrichment statistics
and the diagram panel displays reactions
or pathways with
overlaid tissue specific expression data
there are several options available to
export analysis results in various
formats
the downloads button is located at the
left of the analysis tab
in the details panel the following files
can be downloaded
complete or filtered analysis results in
csv format
complete analysis results in json format
identifier mappings of submitted data
and selected resource used for analysis
in csv format a detailed report of the
analysis for top
25 most significant pathways in pdf
format
a list of submitted identifiers that
were not found in csv
format analysis results overlaid on
pathways and reactions can also be
downloaded using the export button in
the diagram panel
this feature takes a screenshot of the
current diagram panel
which can be saved in png jpeg svg
or pdf formats analysis results on the
voronoi pathways view can also be
downloaded using the export button in
the page